Ти починаєш якось жартувати про розтяжки і міни, я розумію, що це абсолютно не етично…
Але, коли тобі треба пережити якісь травматичні спогади, ти починаєш вдаватись до гумору
для того, щоб полегшити сприйняття цього досвіду.
Це голос 23-річної Юлії. Справжня ім’я і обличчя дівчина не хоче розкривати. Вона виросла в Луганську.
Але в 2014 році, коли почались активні бойові дії, разом з родиною змушена була тікати з рідного міста.
Я дуже добре пам'ятаю час перед переїздом, це було закінчення 10 класу, ми всі мріяли про наступний рік і про випускний.
Навіть  будучи 10-класницею я намагалась зрозуміти, що відбувається і всі мої однокласники так само.
Ми мали суперечки про, тоді ще його називали Євромайдан, тепер Революція Гідності.
І, звичайно, на уроках української літератури, на уроках історії, або на уроках тих вчителів, які були більш політизовані,
ми говорили, сперечались про майбутнє України і про те що відбувалось.
Спогади дівчини стали одним з експонатів "Музею воєнного дитинства", який днями відкрився в Києві.
На виставці  - її останній квиток на потяг з Луганська.
Ми приїжджаємо на луганську естакаду на таксі, беремо сумки, і батьки дали потримати ці квитки.
І на цьому флаєрі написано “Луганськ -  моє місто” і багато різної реклами і навіть, коли подивишся на цю рекламу,
ти побачиш наскільки це з іншого життя речі. Там ще є новина, о котрій ходить поїзд на Москву, на Київ. І взагалі, поїзди, те чого зараз немає.
І потім я писала в своєму щоденнику, що моя мрія і одночасно страх -  це потяг на Луганськ,
коли можна буде сісти і разом з батьками і повернутись додому.
"Музей воєнного дитинства" в Києві - це понад 130 історій дітей, якіжили чи живуть на Донбасі, в зоні бойових дій.
Це їхні іграшки, книжки, щоденники та спогади, пов'язані з ними. Більшість історій - вкрай болючі...
Цю книжку мені читала мама. Мама і брат загинули…
Через мистецтво свій біль втрати висловлюють й дорослі переселенці.
Як от Сергій Ткаченко - автор картин на виставці "За межею", яка проходила в Києві і розповідала про війну на сході.
Це вигляд донецького залізничного вокзалу з вікна плацкартного вагона.
Останній погляд, який закарбувався в свідомості, коли дивився на рідне|місто, покидаючи його.
Малювати Сергій почав після втечі з окупованого Донбасу.
Це був такий сеанс психотерапії - ми намагалися якось позбутися своїх внутрішніх психологічних травм.
У кожного донеччанина є своя дата. У мене це 5-го червня 2014-го року. Ми з дружиною виїхали на пару тижнів.
Потім ми продовжили цей строк, такий внутрішній дедлайн, до початку серпня, потім до 1-го вересня, тому що діти мали піти в школу і так далі.
Тепер перед собою таких дедлайнів ми не ставимо, але ми просто віримо в те, що рано чи пізно це возз'єднання людей і територій відбудеться.
Це моє рідне місто, цей зв'язок я відчуваю постійно.
Мистецькі проєкти чи музейні виставки - це своєрідна терапія для тих, хто пережив травматичний воєнний досвід.
Втім, потрібні такі виставки і для жителей мирних міст, каже Юлія Скубицька - директорка Музею воєнного дитинства в Україні.
Для нас важливо, аби люди з великих міст, до яких приїхало багато людей з Донбасу чи Криму, краще зрозуміли цих людей,
щоб не було булінгу в школах, дискримінації.
Нам важливо показти дітям і молодим людям,  які мають досвід війни, що вони не самі і що вони важливі і те що з ними сталось варто уваги.
Перший музей, присвячений дорослішанню під час війни, був створений у Сараєві.
Він розповідає про досвід, пережитий дітьми під час війни в Боснії і Герцеговині.
Тепер на кошти німецьких благодійників подібний музей відкрили і в Києві.
З часом виставка подорожуватиме Україною. Юлія радіє, що її історію почують інші.
Ці музеї потрібні для того,  щоб люди хоча б мінімально наблизились до цих історії і хоча б доторкнулись поглядом до цих речей
і відкрили для себе інший світ в  якому є біль і надія, і дитячі спогади,  і приховані травми,
і багато любові, батьківської  родинної  і втрати цієї любові.
Ця ситуація навчила мене цінувати миті проведені з рідними неймовірно сильно.
І, напевно, навчила мене дивитись в майбутнє.
Розуміючи що може від мене залежить щось більше, щось що я ще зроблю в майбутньому.
За час війни на Донбасі загинуло понад двісті сорок дітей і близько п’ятисот отримало травми.
250 тисяч дітей, за даними Мінсоцполітики, мусили, як Юлія, покинути малу батьківщину через військовий конфлікт.
Обстріли на сході України не припиняються.